la determinación siempre ha sido una
característica de sirenas Jamaica
Williams la leyenda este figraf fue
víctima de su poderío en la final de
Indian Wells de 1999
ese año se convirtió en la primera
afroamericana en ganar un gran slam el
escenario su casa el Abierto de Estados
Unidos estaba a días de cumplir los 18
años
a nivel mental en la cancha no me iba a
rendir ante nada después de que gane el
primer set quería terminar con fuerza y
lo hice comenzó una carrera imparable 23
torneos grandes individuales y 39 en
total contando sus títulos en dobles y
dobles mixtos serena y su hermana Venus
dominaron el tenis entre las dos suman
también 8 medallas de oro olímpicas su
padre Richard abandonó su empleo para
dedicarse a entrenarlas Venus en la
mayor estaba llamada inicialmente a
Sierra gran estrella pero fue Serena
quien rompió todas las barreras hasta
convertirse en un icono del deporte pero
las polémicas la persiguieron como
sombra
dejó de participar justamente en Indian
Wells durante 14 años tras ser víctima
de la hostilidad del público que la
acusaba de amaños de partidos Entre ella
y su hermana A manos de Richard en 2009
estalló contra una juez de línea en la
semifinal del abierto de Estados Unidos
en 2018 perdió la oportunidad de
conquistar su ansiado título 24 de Gran
slam para empatar el récord de margaret
tras un choque con el juez de silla al
que tildó de Ladrón su cuerpo fornido
fue objeto de crítica Y tuvo que
someterse a frecuentes pruebas
antidoping sorpresa llevándola a
denunciar discriminación
su último título grande llegó en
Australia en 2017 que ganó estando
embarazada a su hermana Venus tras el
parto de su hija Alexis Olimpia generó
Escándalo en Roland garros de 2018 con
un ceñido de traje negro que llevó por
razones médicas y que la organización
rechazó dijeron por faltarle el respeto
al deporte contestó meses después
jugando con un tutú en el chopin en la
antesalada su retiro publicó una columna
en la revista vogue puede que la mejor
palabra para describir cómo me encuentro
esa evolución estoy aquí para contarles
que estoy evolucionando lejos del tenis
hace otras cosas que son importantes
para mí
dedicada ahora a la familia a los
negocios y la defensa de las mujeres y
los afrodescendientes Serena Williams
abandona las canchas un icono que
demostró ser más grande que el deporte
mismo